oh they are good morning is it my name
it to be
are you down easy
come on I won't hesitate to paint these
walls and color God gave you their
Cooper do what what is that what
happened Gary Tison just busted out of
prison nobody got hurt
we're 100 miles gone dad zap I'm gonna
bust them back in
you Dorothy Tarson what's this all about
her husband is escaped from Arizona
State Penitentiary you need to come with
fake Gary Tison listen Ted thing thing
that has no heart thing then get
whatever it wants no matter the cost
even if it's his own flesh and blood
I'll keep our heads about us and Uncle
Joe's gonna get that plane here and
we're gonna be in Mexico free and clear
you know the law can't keep apart what
God meant to be together you can have
anything you want in this world long as
you know how to stay
I take you nobody's gonna get hurt right
look mister I'm gonna do whatever you
set the car for money or whatever else
my Gary is a good man he was dealt his
hand from the bottom of the deck and
it's been stacked against him ever since
and sometimes good men they listen to
bad ones and it's on me to see that
nobody else has to pay Tyson's dead but
Tyson himself
we're doing right now something like
this you want to get people feeling
sorry for these animals she's out of her
mind
Dorothy - I think I get her to talk them
into turn themselves in Oh they've done
you got no reason killing anybody yeah
we're all this boy Donny I need to know
that
raided our
you